they'll go up against advert alzheimer's
and burt will come after these nats
hitters with this assortment of pitches
on the ground out to short bae is to his
left collects throws to first and gets
the speedy turner
and a swing and a miss he gets soto
he had a strikeout good start
and a pitch up face it
they were shifted
now we can walk up kyle schwarber in
chicago number 12 kyle schwarber
[Music]
contreras
and schwarber with the greeting and
kyle tips his cap
just to shade over 10 000 here
and those two guys still having a chat
with ben may just kind of looking up
it's like the weekly wreck softball game
hey how you doing man yeah
that one hit on the ground to first
rizzo gobbles it up underhands to al
zalai
and schwarber is retired
john lester makes his way out to the
mound
[Music]
it's against his nature i think to dolph
the cap in that situation he wants to
try to put that aside and just compete
this is an overwhelming moment for john
lester no doubt about it
he's trying to collect himself out there
rip down into center field and contreras
has a base hit
in the year softly hit right field soto
coming out falls for a knock
contreras racing for third and bryant
dunks one in there at the corners
anthony rizzo
against john lester
in the air left field
schwarber backpedaling kyle is under it
and makes the catch tagging from third
is wilson contreras
and rizzo a sac fly one-nothing cubs
[Music]
that'll take care of a few pitches up in
the inning close at first out the call
turner harrison bell the nets turn their
31st double play of the year
grounded up the middle and duffy with
the base knock so matt duffy
begins the bottom of the second with a
single
cubs lead by a run here's jason hayward
he has hit very well against leicester
in their head-to-head battles out
towards left field schwarber on the move
wow
a home run the opposite way for jason
hayward he takes his former teammate
deep fourth of the year and it is
three-nothing a very good swing of the
bat right here home run number four
one and two with one out
perfect bottom of the zone john lester
carves up being half for his first
strikeout
see catrera stepping out in front of the
plate
just give it john sometimes so the fans
can
love him a bit anthony rizzo taking his
cap off and clapping
[Applause]
this is the first
oh man that's mean
here's trey turner hitting 400 in his
last 10 games yeah trey had four extra
bass hits over the weekend
that's a loud sound
c
u
later almost out of the ballpark trey
turner number 10
a tape measure shot gets the gnats on
the board he continues to swing that hot
bat it's now the cubs three in the
nationals one wilson contrast will lead
off
as lester goes back to work and this one
is drilled in the air over the head of
schwarmer and into the bleachers and
gone wilson contreras will touch them
all and it is 4-1
wilson petraeus has really turned things
around here lately
fastball up
took a tall batter right up the ladder
and john lester's second strikeout
and lester just kind of gets him to two
strikes and toys with him
pitch up two for two going that way
hey take what they give you
and another nice hand this time for kyle
schwarmer who pulled the grounder to
rizzo first time
schwarber to center
half watching it see
you
later
welcome back to chicago kyle schwarber
and it's a one run game a line drive
home run to dead center field his sixth
of the year and schwarber hearing cheers
on a pitch up it goes the other way
and it's run down by juan soto
left field homer right field liner and
one plated extremely well
pitch up
horner fights it off but harrison has it
there's the bounce back one two three
inning that john lester was looking for
as it should be welcoming home a
champion and a former teammate that one
is in there got him looking
pitcher robles is in there got him
looking so alzolai settling in as he's
gotten the first two here in the fifth
that one
in fair ball they'll take a bounce hop
into the stands it's an automatic double
he'll take it
in there body is gone and john lester
freezes the pinch hitter lester at 72
pitches going to work on javi baez the
cubs clean up hitter
that's hammered right field baez way
back and gone
javia no doubter the opposite way
his ninth of the season and some
insurance
cubs lead at 5-3 and that is going to do
it for john lester and we'll listen in
as the fans will give him a nice hand
teammates go and meet him on the mound
dave martinez takes the baseball and has
a couple of words
10 000 plus showing their love john
lester done for the night back at
wrigley
[Music]
on the ground through the left side base
hit
horner comes in sogar comes through at
6-3
[Applause]
broken back base hit
trey turner to second
big groan from the crowd juan soto will
take
a knock any way he can get it
we'll see if they have him take one
bases loaded
castro
oh what a play
nico horner
might have just saved the game for the
cubs
if he doesn't make that play it's a six
to five game
and maybe more to come
fair ball that gets past soto
rizzo chugging for second and anthony
will stop there
[Applause]
that one line base hit out into right
center field rizzo around third
anthony comes in jason hayward with his
third rbi and the cubs have opened up a
7-3 lead
here is the major league debut of tommy
nance cool story this is a guy who was
signed out of indy ball to two
swing and a miss how's that save that
ball strikeout tommy nance in his first
major league strikeout congratulations
making his major league debut
trying to finish off hernandez and the
naz
tapped towards third duffy on the
backhand
ball game cubs win
tommy nance finishes it out
a memorable night here at the ballpark
hugs from contreras
way to go tommy really cool